I'm doing right have a clay before at
Google hey BB of product management and
who's helping to create stuff like this
thing this clip what the heck is a bunch
of GoPros on a tripod that takes
pictures all at once everything around
you or even shoots video that way so
that's what we call a jump camera today
what we announced is something called
jump which is a set of technologies
including a camera but also some
software and then a player that lets
anyone capture an experience or an event
and then share it in a way that others
anyone can experience as if they're
stepping into the video that all around
them most prettiest it's virtual in the
way that it captures so I've how to
describe this is someone listening out
or something i would say it's like a
part of a wedding cake with camera stuff
all around it suree you can call it a
wedding cake made of cameras and what it
does is capture 16 viewpoints that ever
really took off a lot of brides up there
I don't think they'd be very happy now
um it captures 16 viewpoints and then a
bunch of software that we've written
that runs in the Google cloud actually
takes the 16 viewpoints and turns them
into thousands of viewpoints all the way
around the circumference of the the
camera array and we can then turn those
viewpoints into the final product dr
video that again you can step this is a
cardboard device and you stick your
phone in the back of this piece of
carved with a couple of cheap lenses
that also you have this experience of
seeing things in three dimensions that's
right so cardboard it's just a piece of
cardboard with some lenses and you
assemble it and then put your smartphone
in it and it turns your smartphone into
a fully functional the arguer and so
when you view jump content in cardboard
it's stereo as in three-dimensional and
you can look all around you it really
just feels like you're there and it does
are showing some looking sort of
something it's really you went to
Iceland and to Japan's because i was
staying in the middle of a tribe of a
track or something when two cars with
skinny that's cool too so toppy let's go
much bigger picture example so what does
this mean for the business of Google how
does this help Google garner revenues
how does this help Android be more
relevant what Google from the beginning
has been about organizing the world's
information and
it universally accessible and useful and
we really think of this is a very
natural extension of that capturing the
world's places events important moments
in history and organizing them in a way
that anyone anywhere can experience for
all timing I think there's something
important special on that so I see this
very much aligned with the core of what
Google does so is it that being
information the experience of being in a
place as a great time capturing that
information with this wedding cake of
cameras trained and then what like where
does the revenue happen what do I hear
the cash register key story yeah yeah so
as with every Google product or most
Google products we've started like we
did with surge like we do maps with
YouTube just getting the product right
getting the user experience right and
then we assume that we'll figure out how
to build a business out of it later
right now the technology is so new
really just focus on making a great user
experience a great product when we
assume that we'll be able to figure out
how to build a business and all these
people that people crowd at the people
crowding into our shot the people the
people crowding into this event there
are people trying to figure out what a
business case for these things
partnerships they want to strike with
Google devices they the hardware they
might want to make for google well this
is just so new it the approach that
we're taking here is fundamentally
different in more advanced than anything
that we're aware of and the results the
quality of the imagery is just so
impressive so I think many people just
been shocked by just how high quality
how vividly the jump video junk VR video
can put you someplace else near things
are near far things are far you can look
all around and I think that the
businesses the potential use cases for
that are many one of the other things we
announced today we call expeditions
which enables teacher is to take their
classes on field trips to anywhere
that's a trip in other way it's capsule
of courses that is maybe one of the
biggest obstacles and you saw some of
the clay Jerry cool stuff very cool
stuff from google out of a Google i/o
conference here in San Francisco